there is a place of singular horror
amongst these burnt-out oil tanks a
place where people were killed and
thrown away a spot so terrible Islamic
state has tried to cover it up with is
in retreat officials from an
International Commission have begun to
investigate their deeds and their
inquiries have led them to this dirt
track yeah this is this is the way yeah
this is the way this is what we are
looking for so now we are trying to find
how we can arrive to 12 I'll kiss for
the sinkhole this delegation has
traveled up from Baghdad to examine a
great hole called the Casa where it's
thought is disposed of thousands of
bodies Murphy what do you think there's
a lot of IEDs there's a problem is has
saturated the area with landmines
several people have lost their lives
trying to get there we agreed with the
Iraqi government from yesterday but we
have the forces and they have to support
us with the demonic team but now we
arrived but there is no demonic team
with us and the head of the district
police said he wasn't getting involved
movement I know bizarre not much
initiative on Aikido
Islamic state has provided its own
evidence from the house for this video
published two years ago bloodstains line
the craters rim while lifeless bodies
dot in slopes the investigators couldn't
examine the sinkhole so we put a drone
up in the air we soon realized that is
had tried to fill in the entire hole
although one area was beginning to slip
it looked like there were a number of
vehicles at the bottom eyewitnesses say
militants drove trucks loaded with
prisoners into that pit eyewitnesses
like the local village head how many
bodies do you think could be down that
hole well is my duty to tell focused
California is doing it that's
extraordinary self-immolate
that our most loyal forever and wahoo
vilius alla Hadid tells me I entered
that Kuhlman 1200 short a robot doctor
or alien delegation members swap numbers
with the village chief who said he knew
a man whose brothers had been thrown
down the hole and in a crowded refugee
camp south of Mosul
we found Tamara solemn the 40 year old
still had several pictures of his
brother fossil who worked for the local
council and Mohamed and Khalid who were
police officers when did you last see
your brothers my initial a madness -
that's awesome
temir says is went to towns and villages
rounding government employees up the
vast majority he thinks were taken to
the cuff sir my fooling with Angela role
the Commission plans to exhume the
bodies but it's going to take some time
to reach the site still people need to
know what's happened in this toxic
windswept place John sparks Sky News
near Mosul